rajabov he is so good he knows how to
get into his comfort zone
probably more than any other top player
right now and okay we see magnus serve
with a different hand
he does open with the queen's pawn this
time queen's pawn opening
both sides bringing their knights out
you know what i'm going to say
i was gonna suggest a different move i
thought he might pick up his knight and
move it to
another square um i'm really
fascinated as to which approach oh okay
he's gone for
the fianchetto system the fianchetto is
this porn move
and the reason you put the pawn there is
to develop the light squared bishop on
the most
and the longest diagonal possible and
now we see
a very very tricky move who favored this
setup with black
they tend to be counter attackers they
tend to
they tend to allow white to gain a bit
more space here
but they do fight back against that
space they do lash out later and
magnus it looks like okay he jumps
forward with his knight this is
perfectly
viable as well i've seen magnus play
this actually with both colors
or maybe one of the lesser less critical
moves yeah and
it's the best move now is to do what
rajib has just done which is
capture the night and now it becomes
all about the
the left side of the board the queen
side and uh it's going to be about
displacing
and making the black queen there
inconvenient
um okay yep so black's queen and black's
bishop are both attacking white's knight
in the middle of the board right now
that white knight
had to retreat uh not ideal there maybe
from magnus carson bringing his back
bringing his knight back to a lesser
square
now white finally has castle the king
however so magnus
he won't be so happy that there has been
a set of trades it's a little more of a
simple type of position
so ratchet both will be comfortable but
there's still some tension
black there his queen was attacked from
white's bishop he just shuffles it
to the side this position right now you
see the bishop on the light square
that is now on the longest diagonal and
so is blacks
ah and what you see here happening from
magnus is that it's a common scenario
that uh the bishops are
really powerful on this really long
diagonal so what you're going to see
is quite ideal to actually make some
trades it's the greenfield defense it's
all about that bishop the bishop that
fianchez itself
along the longest diagonal opponent in
the play magnus app
and why and the play magnus app already
has a variety of opponents
has magnus has judith polgar wesley so
and even
magnus's dad and you can see that uh
just to take the moves there white has
moved the rook
getting ready to support the idea of
pushing pawns
in the center and uh rajab replied
with uh on developing the light square
bishop you need maybe
four or five preparatory moves but okay
rajabov does try to stop it he does
allow that trade of bishops best
defender of his king has been traded off
and i feel that the black knight is a
little bit offside there on the right it
should perhaps be
on the left side of the board some cool
answers oh i'm not getting the chance
[Laughter]
white comes and gives a check to the
king the king steps back
and uh once again magnus has to decide
on his plan
and uh rajesh agarwal says
and uh you can see there that uh magnus
is attacking the black knight
accomplished whatever is very very good
and plus he would be right quite an
energetic risk-taking opponent i think
yeah
he has to move to and rajab finds it
otherwise that knight was in big trouble
like i can move a rook i could also push
a pawn i was
gonna say it's so tempting it's very
hard for a human to resist
pushing forward in the center and
surprise surprise rajabov tries to get
the queens off the board
he tries to simplify the position
very sensible though white is gaining
space when you don't have so much space
when you are cramped when you're being
attacked
actually as black is it often does
release the tension
i think he should have taken a time out
to to prevent it
okay black bringing his rook across not
rushing with the queen trade um he just
defends the black knight with his rook
you guys first saw that it's the tense
semi-final both of them
yeah yeah i mean it's so much
maneuvering so much sophistication going
on i mean
both players have to be on form
and in concentration mode just to take
advantage of those
small opportunities that will be
presented we always talk about this in
other sports as well football who is the
greatest of all time and it's like
we can never know you know times change
the ball in football changes the field
changes
everything changes but we can actually
figure out who is the greatest of all
time and just putting them up against
each other at the same age
if not maybe you try and improve a piece
you try and solidify but black retreated
his bishop
to a square where it is simply terrible
and now black has given magnus
uh roger bob has given magnus the time
to kick back that black knight
that black knight has lost so much time
in this game but
i'm worried about both of black's pieces
now the black knight is terrible the
black bishop
is terrible and look at this stockfish
below
the player's cameras suggests three
moves
all of them give white an advantage
white pieces to black bishop meanwhile
even worse and look at this magnus
pushing forward with his pawn that black
bishop
cannot move and it probably will not
move now for the next dozen turns
that black bishop is i mean i just can't
believe rajabov has made his piece that
bad i just feels like
okay he doesn't go for it immediately he
blocks things up but look at magnus
stepping forward i
i think these last few moves rajabov is
almost self-destructing
slowly improve all his pieces and push
everything on the right side
and uh just uh david just a quick
question like
how would you look at this position okay
we see some trades happening
i mean how would you look at this it
looks smitely impressive for white
but uh how do you kind of just gauge
that maybe black is doing a very
sophisticated fortress
magnus remember he gave an interview a
few years ago magnus does not believe in
fortresses
he doesn't believe that going passive is
the way to save a game it's a venomous
uh bishop suddenly you push this pawn
forward you unleash this bishop's attack
against the undefended black rook and
this is winning for white the black rook
would have to move and white's pawn is
just stepping forward so black in the
end
did give up that pawn as we mentioned
it's just impossible to defend it
uh in this position we did hear the ping
there
rajabov just bringing his knight forward
allowing that pawn to drop but now
magnus he's a pawn up and with a
dominant position look at this bishop
how bad
is that piece i played him over the
board as well um sometimes when he's
leaning back
he thinks he's okay he thinks he's in
control but he's not too excited by the
position when magnus is leaning back
we've seen it before right
yeah but as soon as he leans forward he
kind of tenses up he
is focused ready for the kill and okay
the white knight improving itself
black's pawns stepping forward trying to
fight for some space but
it's too late bishop gets in the way of
the black king from bringing itself to
the left side magnus does block up
the right flank and play is going to
switch over to the other side now black
is unable to
participate with his bishop and with his
king white's king is now going to walk
its way over to the center okay yeah
he said he's giving him a bad position
give him a terrible position
but give him one position he can't win
it
okay so he pushes yeah i like this move
uh
pusher pawn fix the pawns on light
squares
and uh there you can see that rajaboff
has managed to open
one line for the rook small victory uh
okay he does
take those pawns off the board black can
give a check with his rook right now
that's the move i would expect to see
but magnus can block that check
so if black's rook comes down to attack
white's king from the side
okay it doesn't it goes the whole way
down the board um but there are no
targets there
magnus is just improving his bishop
controlling squares what else can you do
you can barely move the black knight you
can't move the black bishop give a check
give a check don't
don't top off rooks uh resist that
temptation
keep your rook alive because that's
black's only active exactly
um otherwise you're just giving a free
hand for the wife for the white king
just to walk
its way into the left side of the board
and uh
okay now just okay magnus
again i mean well you can't really do
too much can you
yeah roger above okay instead of moving
the black rock up and down he just
moves the black king um one move here
that actually is
okay magnus he is so precise he finds
the top computer suggestion
for sure in this one he needs magnus to
maybe panic and lose control
because magnus has complete and utter
control right now okay the blackberry
did drop back as expected white's knight
didn't attack the black pawn from the
front as we
were maybe predicting he jumps forward
with the white knight
um okay that makes perfect sense as well
it's just a more active way of
implementing the same plan i don't think
black ever wants to capture the white
knight
with his bishop black's bishop is
terrible but if you capture the white
knight then white would create a next
a very powerful passport and now timor
rajab with his last move yeah
just okay traded a set of pawns on that
right side but that doesn't change
anything in the position
into the action and black's position is
just
creaking i mean is any hope i don't see
anything
i mean literally zero i think at this
point
um yeah i think white can just step
forward with the white king white can
improve the white rook
the white thing yep there we go white
stroke jumps into the position
we did mention black's bishop being
terrible it is defended by black's
knight right now it's not
under uh it's not under fire yet but if
black ever does get tempted to capture
the white knight then
white just establishes i mean i keep
using the word dominant but
establishes a dominant pawn and black
black will be completely paralyzed
roger bob just resigns wow wow
timor jabo he resigns the third game
against magnus carlsen